(audience applauding)
(chiming music)
♪ I'm hearing sleigh bells ♪
♪ I'm seeing snow ♪
♪ I've waited all year, baby,
just to see those reindeer ♪
♪ Watch them as they go ♪
♪ Home by the fireside ♪
♪ Twinkling lights ♪
♪ I've waited all year, baby ♪
♪ Just to see that sleigh
flying to the night ♪
♪ All the lights, all of the fun ♪
♪ All of us here, all of us one ♪
♪ Only a gift, only a toy ♪
♪ Only for a good girl and boy ♪
♪ The greatest party you ever did see ♪
♪ I'm hearing sleigh bells ♪
♪ I'm seeing snow ♪
♪ I see those snowy scenes ♪
♪ I've waited all year, baby, ♪
♪ Just to see those reindeer
watch them as they go ♪
♪ Home by the fireside ♪
♪ Twinkling lights ♪
♪ All of those pretty lights ♪
♪ I've waited all year, baby ♪
♪ Just to see that sleigh
flying to the night ♪
♪ A party for you, and for me ♪
♪ A party for a magical scene ♪
♪ Ain't no party like Christmas Eve ♪
♪ I'm hearing sleigh bells ♪
♪ Hear those sleigh bells ring ♪
♪ I'm seeing snow ♪
♪ I see those snowy scenes ♪
♪ I've waited all year, baby ♪
♪ Just to see that sleigh
flying to the night ♪
(audience applauding)
Give it up for the band!